live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show where we help people build
wealth do work that they love and create
actual amazing relationships thank you
for joining us America George Campbell
Ramsey personality is my co-host today
and he is the host and co-host of uh
smart money happy hour and the George
Campbell show which uh the George camel
YouTube channel what do we call that I
think it's just my name on YouTube who
knows anymore camel with a K that's
right just how to find it yeah and that
show has come out to rave reviews and a
huge number of views right out of the
gate so be sure you guys check that out
anyway open phones here at triple eight
eight two five five two two five Austin
starts this hour in Nashville hey Austin
welcome to the Ramsey Show yeah
all right thank you man sure what's up
so I uh Nashville Tennessee I'm in data
analytics and I have a ridiculous amount
of student debt right now
um with graduate with a business degree
and I'm just wondering how if you would
recommend any options that I have to
refinancing the student loans and kind
of getting my my monthly interest in
monthly payment down
cool so how much student loans do you
have right now
so a little over 155
what do you make
uh currently I made gross about forty
three thousand UH 60 net
when did you get out of school
about 20 I would say 2015 2016.
and you're in what do you do in data
analytics to pay so poorly most of our
guys make 140.
correct yeah I kind of moved from
another industry I was getting out of a
company that was a very poor company
it's actually under now uh so I kind of
took the first thing that I could get
and unfortunately made the poor decision
not to um not to get the the amount that
I needed I just did something to switch
okay how long have you been at the wrong
job
uh the wrong job before was two years uh
this wrong job the one where you don't
get paid enough
about a year I do have a raise coming up
I'm sure how much that's going to be but
I should know in the next few weeks well
regardless of if the raise is 20 grand
maybe but I think you're gonna do better
finding another job that pays probably
double what you're making right now the
data analytics space is wild it's yeah
it's not forty thousand dollars a year
I'm serious I'm not trying to be mean to
you but if you know how to do data
analytics you need to make a lot more
and and you need to make a lot more to
pay off 155 000. so the ratio that
you're looking at is not can I refinance
this and keep it the rest of my life
because I make it manageable
no we don't want Sallie Mae in the house
anymore she needs to leave not make her
manageable I don't want to give her a
haircut and put her in the corner I want
her to leave
that's your goal for that for for
getting the debt right so refinancing to
get a lower interest rate or to get
lower payments is translated as
mathematically I'm going to keep this
debt forever
because lower payments means longer term
you know that right
dessert yeah so I mean you got a
business degree so you know how that
math works so ins let's change the goal
from lower payments to Lo and lower
interest to how fast can I pay this off
and that is big hairy chunks of
principal payments like I don't know go
get seven jobs and pay ten thousand
dollars a month and be done in 15 months
probably not going to happen exactly
that way but wouldn't that be fun so
when you start looking at it that way
you we realize why George and I
immediately went after the job because
you've got what we call a shovel to
whole ratio problem the whole year ends
155 000 the shovel you got is forty two
thousand your shovel's not big enough
for the hole you're in and we
immediately went asking you to get a
bigger shovel for your sake that's where
we went rather than trying to say how
can we keep Sally Mae in the house and
keep her happy
understood that makes sense yeah even at
a zero percent interest rate it would
still take you seven or eight years to
pay off this debt if you keep making
what you're making yeah exactly exactly
so if you work seven days a week I have
I have three part-time jobs that I do uh
to try to fix that but I think you're
right all of that is forty two thousand
no sir all that together is about 73 uh
with the other job I was just speaking
just with my man my main channel so the
way I looked at it when I was broke
Austin and I was in my 20s and I lost
everything the way I looked at it was
not only how can I make the most money
for a short period of time I'll do
anything I mean we'll scrub septic tanks
with a toothbrush whatever I got to do
right and so what have I got to do to
make the most money that's legal and
moral the fastest so that I can clean up
the mess and then I can choose things
that are more uh uh
self-actualizing things that are better
for a long-term career thinking I can
choose things differently once I get the
mess cleaned up but yeah so your
part-time jobs are you you're not afraid
of hard work so that's a good part of
the answer yeah so yeah but let's look
at the heart the part times jobs uh you
know how can I make the most money in
the shortest period of time and look at
a job change because if you're in data
analytics honey you're underpaid uh and
so uh you know what if that's really
what you're doing if you really
understand data analytics you have an
expertise in the field and you're doing
that if you're just crunching a number
somebody else is giving you that's not
data analytics you're you know you're
you're a gopher and that's different but
uh which is about what you're being paid
but the uh but but if you actually can
take a project and think through the
model and build out the data analytics
model and come back with the
recommendations that the data is telling
the business owner then you have a value
much greater than that in this world
today yeah if you can get that full-time
job up to 80 plus the side jobs now
we're talking now sweet spot side jobs
yes ones that bring in bank because we
don't want to keep them any more than we
want to keep the student loan and I hope
that's all the debt we didn't we didn't
find out if there's more to the picture
but man that's just a lot to come out of
school with six figures in debt and
making 40 Grand it's just defeating yeah
and and you know you can get on some
long-term career tracks I mean Ken
Coleman's stuff will help you make some
decisions on if this is the field you
want to be in how can you make some
moves that are good now and good long
term so let me send you a copy of Ken's
book from paycheck purpose where
hopefully we can even align all of this
money making stuff we're talking about
with a good long-term strategy that
includes purpose includes doing things
that matter with your life that you're
excited about on Monday morning and uh
all of that will help yeah and if you
can maximize your time doing those side
hustles that's key because if you do
three side hustles that pay 10 or 15
bucks each and if we can replace that
with a 45 an hour side hustle now we're
talking because you started mowing lawns
or pressure washing that's a different
ball game so I would look at how to
maximize your time and on top of that
make the most doing it that's going to
help clean this mess up perfect it's a
lot good stuff Austin good stuff hey
thank you for calling and we'll hang on
uh Austin another Austin will pick up
and get you a copy of that book Austin
talk to Austin and um Roger Roger and uh
yeah so um he'll get you a copy of that
book and of Ken's and help you get going
so folks that's what you're looking at
is um
the a good way to do this is what we
call Big math don't don't get caught up
in the nuanced interest rate or the
nuanced payment amount just say 155 000.
divided by three is fifty thousand
I can't do 50 000 a year
three years but divided by ten thousand
dollars okay that's 15 months oh wait oh
or 15 years if it's ten thousand dollars
a year what are we going to do I'm
choosing fifteen you start just looking
at it that way and then you go how can I
take this thing out this is the Ramsay
show
[Music]
hey Dr John deloney here I'm a huge fan
of both meditation and prayer and good
mental health includes slowing down
gaining control of your thoughts and
plugging into something bigger than you
and Halo makes it easy to start a daily
practice of meditation prayer and
finding peace Hollow is the number one
Bible app in the world and you can
tailor content towards your faith
tradition from scripture readings and
prayers to meditation and journaling
hallow makes it easy to practice prayer
meditate and build a deeper more
meaningful spiritual life and ReDiscover
true peace go to hollow.com Ramsay today
to get three months of hallow for free
that's hallow.com Ramsay
thank you
foreign
[Music]
personality is my co-host today and uh
stepping into the guest seat Alex for
Mosey I'm gonna mess it up her Mosey a
first generation Iranian American
entrepreneur I just spent the morning
with him we did his podcast I was a
guest he's an investor a philanthropist
known for his expertise in customer
acquisition and monetization it's a huge
deal on YouTube has done some amazingly
large business deals including scaled
and exited seven companies uh for in
excess of 46 million dollars so been a
joy hanging out with this young guy he's
getting things done 1.3 million YouTube
subscribers welcome good to have you
brother I'm honored to be here well
we're honored to have you with us thanks
for hanging out yeah this is big I've
been following you on YouTube for a long
time and then we had Graham Stefan on I
was on his show and he was like gotta
hang out with Alex so you're on now and
what's interesting is that you mentioned
in one of your YouTube videos that Dave
gave Graham Stefan some of the wisest
advice you'd ever heard around investing
and I want you to share that so Graham
was had his big pie chart of his
Investments on the table he said Dave
what am I doing wrong here what should I
be doing and Dave rather than just like
giving him like oh you need to be 16
here and 13 here he said well if this
pie chart were your knowledge and
expertise how would you divide it up
he's like well I'd probably say I'm 85
real estate maybe like 15 like my
knowledge of stocks and that more or
less mirrored what Graham's actual
Investment Portfolio looked like and the
big takeaway that I had when I was
seeing that was it wasn't one particular
methodology it wasn't like oh you got to
get into stocks you got to get into
crypto you got to get into obviously
like
I'm baiting right
um but it was more so do what you know
and when my wife and I uh exited our
company and we had taken a sizable
distributions prior to that I hadn't
really come up with an investment
strategy because the investment strategy
was in the beginning don't be poor
um it's a good start I like that one but
then after that it was just like I had
everything in indexes and I wanted to
take a more active role and the only
thing I felt like I knew good enough was
business and so I had gone all the way
to the edge on you know two three four
big real estate transactions and right
before I needed to send the money I
pulled back so I was like I don't know
this stuff and so uh once I got
basically gave myself permission or felt
like you'd give me some sort of like
verbal permission to just do what I know
um acquisition.com kind of started and
became our family office for everything
that we do investing which is
exclusively businesses that we feel like
we can add value to yeah and it's a
space you know you're comfortable in you
should never put money in something that
you don't understand and don't know and
because some guy in a good suit said to
and the only thing he may own is a good
suit so that's probably not where we're
taking the advice so really that that's
really really really important okay so
you started with nothing
over 50 million dollar net worth in
excess of that on this one transaction
yeah I know you're probably north of 100
million at that point
um
and uh the Iranian
American so your parent your for your
first generation yeah first American
yeah okay so your parents came from Iran
both just my dad just your dad okay
mom's having a really good friend that
uh both of his parents came here and uh
also unbelievably successful uh and
financially and sometimes I think uh I
was talking to my friend Brian buffini
who's Irish and he has a book out called
The Immigrant Edge and so the mentality
that comes off that George's parents are
his second first generation Middle
Eastern Middle Eastern as well so uh uh
there's an immigrant Edge that goes with
that what is do you think the number one
mindset as you work with investors in
companies that keeps people broke
they subscribe to
what everyone else around them who is
poor tells them about how to get rich
so they take people Poor People's advice
on how to make money hmm
and so as a result of that they keep
doing the wrong stuff or they don't do
anything at all and a lot of them sit
into this area of uh you know the
paralysis analysis they're like I need
to find the perfect thing and meanwhile
10 years later they're still trying to
wait to find the perfect thing and they
haven't started anything yeah
yeah how do you become a writer right
yeah how you become an investor invest
yeah I used to because I I talk a lot
about sales stuff because I think it's a
really good entry uh thing for anybody
who wants to you know take control of
their own income and cost no money to
get into and all you have is skill is
that you know you can read 100 books on
sales but the first thousand cold calls
you do you'll learn more than all the
books that that you read up to that
point experience as a mighty teacher oh
100 and uh it's interesting with skill
proficiency but uh people will put off
you know it takes 20 20 hours of of
concentrated work to become proficient
at most like playing the guitar playing
the piano learning to do a cold call 20
hour proficient of actual dedicated work
but people will wait a decade to do
those first 20 hours because they're
afraid
fears holding them back because they
don't want to fail a lot of the times
yeah they don't want the Judgment that
they think is coming along from people
who aren't actually paying attention to
them to begin with
uh multi-millionaire uh young age
entrepreneur Alex Hermosa Our Guest this
segment you can catch him on YouTube uh
be sure and look that up uh that's
h-o-r-m-o-z-i if you don't know and you
can check him out at his website at
acquisition.com so what do you feel like
I mean you had a couple really big hits
along the way
um the actual the liquidity event was a
big hit but the building up was gradual
and um I mean it wasn't like you had
like you hit the lottery and 20 minutes
had this kind of network but so you
built a company sold it and that that
was a lot of it uh what do you think all
of that has taught you about Building
Wealth out there in America today hey is
it possible and B what do you think the
your the sense of hope or the sense of
principles around it what did you what's
your takeaway
so a 100 possible B I think um I Define
sadness as ignorance as in you don't
know what options you have
and so like whenever you feel hopeless
it's because you don't know what to do
and so when I felt sad in my life I
think to myself like this is because I
don't know what to do which means that
this is a problem I can solve because
all I have to do is figure out what I
need to do and then that even gives me
my first action step which is like oh I
just don't know great and so
um for me solving that has been a
Perpetual education process and nowadays
there's so much free information that
exists on the internet like you can
learn how to flip houses you can learn
how to how to how to sell you can learn
how to code you can learn how to edit
videos like there are all these skills
that that pay entry-level roles 50 60 70
100 200 000 a year that you can learn in
eight weeks and so for the people who
are who are willing to just put in the
eight weeks and then apply for the jobs
you can get way ahead well there's a lot
of young people out there and you know I
get the messages they're 17 they're 18
they call into the show they're going
hey I want to invest I want to build
wealth I don't want to wait till I'm 60.
I don't want to work a job I hate do the
401K thing they want to make money
really quickly and a lot of times they
want to do it the wrong way what is the
advice you constantly give those folks
yeah so
um I say like you can invest in the S P
500 I was like but I prefer people
investing the SME 500 which is you're
always going to get higher Returns on
investing in your own education your own
skill set compared to any stock market
and so like a really real example of
this is a buddy of mine has a daughter
she's 17 I think she just turned 18.
um and she's she's working at a bowling
alley minimum wage job you know popcorn
right and
she said uh or he told her he's like you
know you can triple your income if you
just get a certification become a
phlebotomist it takes two days it's 500
bucks
and by taking 500 she could invest in
the S P 500 and at 18 years old maybe
it'll be a ton of compounding but if she
invests 500 in getting the certification
and then two days later she triples her
income
probably a better investment in buying
the certification than forever having a
three times higher Baseline for what she
can make and I think that's just like a
micro example of how much skills can
give you more cash flow to invest in
everything else and so my my belief is
always keep reinvesting the skills
because that raises your Lifeline your
your lifetime Baseline of earning
potential that's so good and valuable
valuable education uh is always costs
minuscule amounts to not all education
but I said valuable usable utilitarian
value she can immediately go and do
something with that it's not like I
collect degrees for a living no this is
like but but studying something that is
usable 100 of the time is the best
investment you can make my father came
here with a thousand dollars and he
didn't speak English but he had a
medical degree
and so he's always been big on education
for me and if you look at it as an
actual investment I mean he fled during
the revolution in Iran he said they took
everything we had but they couldn't take
my education
and so it's something that can never be
taken from it from you you can't lose it
in a divorce can't be taxed on it on
your your education itself it
appreciates with time and then the more
educated become the more valuable each
prior skill adds on top it compounds
like if you know how to do math then you
can then learn accounting when you learn
accounting then you can learn investing
or business or whatever like each one
compounds unto itself you got to follow
this guy check him out on YouTube Alex
Hermosa
h-o-r-m-o-z-i for those of you that
aren't familiar with how big a deal he
already is and check him out at
acquisition.com check him out at hormoza
on all his social media and his podcast
is called the game with Alex Hermosa
Alex an honor to meet you today hang out
got a new friend and uh it's been
honored up here on your podcast thanks
for hanging out with us for a few
minutes here it's the honors online
anyway cool
well you've all played the telephone
game the first person Whispers a message
to the second person who Whispers it to
the third and so on around the table
until the original message has
completely changed multiply that
confusion by a hundred if you run a
business with different software systems
that don't talk to each other that's why
there's netsuite by Oracle in the early
days of Ramsey we were using different
systems for all of our business units we
needed one single source for accurate
data netsuite was the software we used
to optimize and take us to the next
level netsuite gave us the visibility
into all of our numbers so that we could
communicate across departments and plan
ahead better and as we grew it scaled
with us next week worked for Ramsey and
it will make a difference for your
business too join the more than 34 000
customers who trust netsuite to help
make them smarter and make better
decisions and level up their operations
to learn more get a free product tour at
netsuite.com Ramsay that's netsuite.com
Ramsay
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
George Campbell Ramsey personality is my
co-host today thank you for joining us
America in the lobby of rams
Ram freestyle
Jen are with us hey guys how are you how
you doing Dave good good good welcome
where do you guys live
near Ashland Ohio jerome'sville actually
but near Ashland Ohio fun good to have
you guys and how much debt have you paid
off
177 thousand dollars all right how long
did that take 12 months good for you and
your range of income during that year we
were about 170 000 to about 220 000.
nice jump in one year yeah what do you
all do for a living
I am a school superintendent in Ohio
school district and I uh do HVAC have my
own business one-man show what caused
the fifty thousand dollar bump in one
year
well she got a pay increase and then
um part of it was just me finally being
able to uh work my business the way I
needed to we've had some medical issues
with my son and we had a few down years
because of that okay all right so it
kind of got a clean spot to run yeah
yeah yes good for you guys what kind of
debt was the 177 000. oh gosh we had his
truck payment we had my dream car
payment we had a land payment we had
some lots of medical debt we had lots of
other debt too little check lines here
where did you sell
I sold my Range Rover oh wow how much
was that it was at the time 43 500 okay
so forty three thousand of the 177
anything else big nope nope we just we
just needed it out yeah did you have
some money in savings you threw at it
too we had a little bit
um we have a couple of rentals that we
had paid cash for before we met Dave
Ramsey and so we had a little bit of
cash there probably maybe ten thousand
dollars there okay so all right and then
I you know and then through this all I
got behind on taxes and uh because of uh
the tax credits that we didn't get
previously that was maybe five thousand
dollars just you know to push us through
the last one you got behind on filing
them yes
then we finally caught up on uh yeah but
it was a stressful part in our
relationship I was pushing him all the
time to get that done you know be
responsible you know just the the eight
years that we've had with our son were
really difficult it got behind and yeah
you know we just we're tired of being
tired you know we were making good money
and we wanted to be able to just feel
comfortable do things yeah what was that
Turning Point 12 months ago you guys are
making good money you're surviving
you're making your payments what made
you go everything's got to go well I
mean I think you know previous to this
she didn't realize it but through our
sons he had brain cancer twice and uh
after the first time I had gone behind
with my suppliers 35 000 luckily they
were family owned and dealt with me with
that but she had no idea that I was
dealing with that and started getting
that caught up and we used part of a
chat or a home equity line to pay for
that
then he was diagnosed a second time with
cancer and I got back behind again about
30 grand and so previous to 12 months
ago I had actually caught that up on my
own
and then through some just through our
church and some marriage counseling you
know we just finally got down to the
roots of hey you should have been open
with me about this and you know we
finally got on page with communication
as a couple you know so how'd you guys
get plugged into the Ramsay way uh we we
finally landed in a church that we liked
in Worcester Ohio Worcester Grace shout
out to Jeff Walter our leader there for
FPU and you know he you know through
church then they offered FPU and you
know we were right at that point where I
was tired of that I mean I'd had
heaviness for you know seven years
waking up she had no idea waking up in
the middle of the night stressing about
man I got to go to the supplier and ask
them to sell me more equipment and I owe
them thirty five thousand dollars but
once I found out we're like game on like
we're gonna get this knocked out we're
gonna get this done and so come perfect
time and we jumped in and wow an FPU was
just that all right this is right in
front of us yeah if we ever needed a
sign this is it that's right second
class she's she looked at me and she's
like I gotta sell my car I'm like it was
awesome that's big that's sentimental
but we went to buy the car and I mean I
was just sick the whole time you know
I'm thinking I got 30 000 hanging over
my head and she wants to buy this you
know beautiful car you know oh yeah yeah
that's incredible car 900 a month it's
incredible bye-bye yeah yeah it was if
you go down to one car did you get
something else we I had had a uh uh
Tacoma that I use as my work truck and
then I had a GMC Sierra that we had
purchased here she settled for that
in the parking lot I love it good for
you well done you guys I'm proud of you
how's it feel to be free you know it's a
lot of weight off the off our chest you
know and it's hard to slow down like
which everyone says that you know we're
we've got a little bit of uh mortgage
left but
um you know it's I listen to you guys
every day on the podcast and you know
it's it's it's hard to not want to help
people you know I see people in my you
know close vicinity whether it be church
family friends that you just want to
help them out and and and turn them to
this system because it really just takes
a lot of weight off your chest wow thank
you I'm so glad we were there for you it
worked out great man thank you and you
guys uh you're impressive because really
what happened with you guys was so much
more than a simple money plan
um this was a marriage come to fruition
the secrets are unveiled we don't have
to hide them we have to carry the stress
there's a lot of things broke loose with
this a lot of kind of freedom in
addition to the debt Freedom yeah I mean
I really think that I mean I've said
that from the beginning is just we had a
common goal you know what I mean you
know just something that it really
brought us closer because we both were
you know headed to that that common
common goal so yeah way to go you guys
very well done we're proud of you good
work hey we've got a the uh live and
give box for you it's the baby
millionaires book that's where you're
tracking towards and of course Total
Money Makeover book you can give that to
someone the Financial Peace University
membership and give that away since
you've been to it and it made such a
difference in your all's life and so
it's a live you get to use some of it
and give a box we'll have that for you
thanks for coming down to visit with us
very proud of you before we go what do
you tell people the key is to getting
out of debt
I think just unity in your marriage and
you know just having that common goal
you know and having that you know just I
don't know
I think that for me it was just
immersing myself into the system and
continually listening to the podcast
listening to people you know you are who
you surround yourself with and you
become who you know the things that you
listen to and expose yourself to and so
that was important to me just to
continually hear the same thing so that
way I was focused on the goal well in
that way you don't think you're crazy
for selling a Range Rover yeah instead
you think you're a hero because the
truth is you're not crazy you're a hero
that's the truth but you know if you're
hanging out with people they're calling
you crazy every day for doing that
instead of people are saying way to go
you're sacrificing to win because you
have a bigger goal in mind than a car
um way to go I mean that's a huge thing
that says so much about who both of you
are the processes that you went through
in this so well done very very very neat
people cool all right Tim and Jen
Ashland Ohio 177
000 paid off in 12 months making 170 to
220 count it down let's hear a debt free
scream is that free screen right three
two one we're debt free
[Applause]
at the end there folks I forgot to
introduce him I apologize but yeah great
job Kaden good work good debt free
scream guys what a story that is how
it's done right there
there is so much that's typical
about where they were
and so that and how far they traveled in
12 months not only with the numbers but
their behavior changes their
relationship changes everything and at
the exact moment Financial Peace
University appears at their Church yeah
as if it was planned you know apparently
someone was planning that it wasn't me
by the way not a coincidence it would be
called God and so uh that's what we call
it around here anyway and uh pretty
impressive to people yeah I mean so many
people wait 12 years to do something
about it they went in 12 months we could
be done with this and focus on our
future and that's what's so powerful
about Financial Peace University it's
not a 10-year get out of debt it's we're
doing this in two years so we can have
the rest of our life with freedom so if
you haven't done it I don't know what
y'all are waiting for head off
everything but the mortgage 177 000
including the sale of a forty three
thousand dollar Range Rover wow in 12
months what are you willing to do to get
that freedom yeah she's willing to do a
lot a whole lot sick and tired of being
sick and tired it makes a difference
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
personality is my co-host today thank
you for joining us America we're glad
you're here
that debt-free scream we're talking
about Financial Peace University what
you discover there is the difference in
knowing what to do and actually doing it
because a lot of you listen to the show
you know the answers you know what to do
but the trick is we got to get you to do
it and in financial fish university
we're going to get you to do it it's
what we do so the classes work for
millions and millions of people after
nine weeks you'll never handle money
again you'll never see money again the
same way
you're gonna have a whole new look on
how the world works so join a Financial
Peace University class at
ramseysolutions.com
FPU
FPU Johnson New York City hey John
welcome to the Ramsey Show
hey Dave thank you so much for taking my
call you guys are incredible well thank
you sir how can we help
uh well I am calling to find out when
you think I should move out of my
parents house and I should specify that
I'm on Long Island not the city uh
because it's actually relevant here uh
so I am a 25 year old uh lawyer I'm
going to be admitted as a lawyer this
coming Tuesday congrats and I will get a
Salary thank you thank you I will get a
salary bump to 80 000 per year uh but
after taxes that's going to be about
five thousand dollars per month
uh I went to law school on a full
scholarship thankfully but unfortunately
I owe forty six thousand dollars in
undergraduate student loans
I'm estimating that without a rent
payment because I'm still with my
parents uh I will be 100 debt free in
about 12 to 15 months
here's the kicker
I live on
East per day to work
to work uh obviously I don't like this
my current plan is to stay with my
parents until I am completely out of
debt then rent an apartment close to
work while I work on baby step three you
work in the city I think this is a
reasonable plan you work in the city
uh pretty close to it I'm in like
Western Nassau County so very close to
Queens yeah okay
um
well John the only way I know how to
answer questions around here is and I'll
let George do the same thing I'm going
to do is what would I do if I woke up in
your shoes uh
for me a commute of three minutes is a
strain three hours is untenable
so mine's 12 minutes and and that pisses
me off and he still drives very fast
yeah and that's driving quick but I
still don't even want to do that so
um I couldn't do it I didn't make I mean
that's like for me I can be in Knoxville
from Nashville in three hours that's
like driving to Knoxville to go to work
every day for me that just blows my mind
no thank you I'm not doing that there's
not a there's not a scenario under which
that's going to happen now I could do a
lot of different things I could take a
job as a lawyer somewhere else and move
to Kansas but I'm not driving three
hours okay so that's off the table for
me and if what that means is you're
going to get out of debt a little slower
oh well uh we're gonna get out a little
slower and is there something else we
can do to patch up our income while
we're a beginning lawyer I don't know
80k is not bad
um uh but they're probably going to try
to kill you the first three years 180k
too they probably don't have any spare
time and you've got a six hour round
trip here no thank you not six hour
total uh three hours oh an hour and a
half each way an hour and a half yeah
it's still untenable for me I I'm not
doing it I'm moving
and I might even move to a whole
different area and get a job somewhere
else but I'm not doing that that's not
it's not on the table for me what do you
think George yeah I'm in the boat of Ira
would rather have three or four
roommates in the city and have a shorter
commute then continue this for any
extended period of time now this is this
doesn't work
um it's not free
the cost is Extreme
and so physical mental emotional yeah
you somehow you've got it in your head
this is free but I mean it's straining
you it's it's you're trashing your car
you're putting them in bazillion miles
on it you got a lot of fuel cost
um I mean it's not free to live there so
um and I'm just the quality of life on
that I'm not doing it but again if it's
untenable to live near work then maybe
you've taken a job in an area you can't
afford to live in
uh and that may mean a whole different
set of issues and changes but at the end
of the day what this points to you it
points out to you is the current way
something's got to change now how much
has to change and that's the only thing
I'm looking at I'm moving John
so thank you for the call we appreciate
you listening and I hope it all works
out for you I hope it's real smooth and
everything goes good and that's not a
slam on your mom and dad it's not a slam
on you living with them if they were 10
minutes away we could have a different
discussion as to when you would move out
but uh they're not so it takes it off
the table yeah I'm with that Erica's
with us in Rochester New York it's New
York segment hi Erica how are you
hey good how are you better than I
deserve what's up
awesome
um so I've been I was laid off about six
weeks ago now
for the past couple weeks and no doors
seem to be opening
I have two small children in daycare and
I'm just like wondering should I just
take them out of daycare stay home and
then we'll just live off my husband's
income
what's his income
right now he makes 65 but he just
graduated with his degree in
occupational therapy so he should be
making at least 80
um the next you know a couple months but
we're not there yet okay what did you
make
I need 90. why we're doing what
uh senior buyers so for manufacturing
and why isn't trying to land on a job
oh why do I not have another job he said
yeah why are they why have you not made
it through the interviews do you think
Brown is just I don't know if economy's
not good it's a tough Market
[Music]
well there's a shortage of workers so
the economy is booming for what you're
trying to do
um
uh you know I think I try to get a
handle on uh what what you think is
going on here uh the only way I know how
to do that is put you in touch with Ken
Coleman's materials Ken is one of our
Ramsay personalities and he has some
wonderful stuff on interviewing
um and I also think that
um I'll send you a copy of one of his
books called the proximity principle and
this idea that you know someone inside
of some of those buildings that can a
help you get in the door and B maybe
even give you a nice recommendation to
push you over the top on some of these
interviews and you'd be surprised about
who you know when you stop and think
about it in a different way so
um
uh dropping your household income by
more than in half because you had a
couple of rough bouts on an interview is
not a plan
uh and if there's another reason that
you don't want to work but it sounds
like you're like I don't want any more
rejection I'm going to stay with the
kids that's what it sounds plenty of
rejection with the kids too but well
it's different it doesn't sound like
your dream is to be a stay-at-home mom
which tells me let's get back to work I
think you're gonna pay a lot less in
daycare uh than you would make a 90
grand and paying for daycare so I think
the ROI is there for you to continue
working if you're making 35k it may be a
wash with paying for all that daycare
expense but I would keep searching keep
hustling use those resources from Ken
and see if you can't land something in a
few months and get that income back up
yeah he's got a Resume Builder
um he's got a whole process on Landing
interviews and getting through them a
lot of that is free at king coleman.com
or click Ken Coleman ramsaysolutions.com
either one meantime I will send you a
copy of his first number one bestseller
it's called the proximity principle to
get in proximity of people but it also
talks about this connectivity uh being
your inroad just sending out resumes and
hoping people pull them out of the stack
it usually does not work yeah the way I
got the job here was knowing someone it
was a loose connection but we kind of
you get one little foot in the door and
that becomes in something and that
becomes a full-time gig and it's amazing
what happens but a lot of people right
now Dave there there are layoffs
happening and we're seeing that even as
the economy is booming what do people do
the first thing when they face that
financially yep that's exactly how that
works it's getting that emergency fund
and making sure you line something up as
soon as possible works for me Guys open
phones here at triple eight eight two
five five two two five Austin is on the
phones Ben is on the board James is our
producer Zach and Andrew are helping us
on video they are the booth dudes they
make the show happen in the booth and um
some days they have a substitution
that's not a dude but on the other days
they are the booth dude yes we do have a
few females occasionally punk rock band
the booth dudes I'm just saying I
wouldn't know that I call them punk rock
but they are very nice gentlemen I
didn't say anything about the rock I
said something about the punks they're
punks for sure this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
hey George Campbell here if you love the
show and you want a deeper dive on your
money Journey we've got a Weekly
Newsletter that gives you helpful
articles and tips on following the
Ramsay way just go to
ramseysolutions.com today to sign up for
the newsletter again that's
ramseysolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS of
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show where we help people build
wealth
do work
that they love and create actual amazing
relationships Jade wash all Ramsay
personality is my co-host today as we
answer your questions here at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
Dave is going to start off this hour in
Indianapolis hi Dave how are you
I'm doing just fine Dave I have been a
major fan and listened to you for over
15 years I have read uh The Total Money
Makeover I have done it practically
though by myself my wife has never been
on board with it but I have got myself
to a place to where I am debt-free
except for my mortgage but I'm 63 years
old and I owe 150 000 on the mortgage
the house is worth about 400 000.
um we have about ninety thousand dollars
on hand in cash and what I have been
thinking and I wanted to ask you I'm so
very very honored again to be talking to
you right now I respect you very very
much in in your whole cast there that
you have thank you uh I'm trying to
think this out and think this through no
credit card debt no no nothing we don't
even have a car payment
um and absolutely nothing but the thing
of it is is that I think that we should
downsize from the bigger house that we
have for a lot of reasons things but I
think moreover I'm not as disciplined as
I could be and I do realize that you
cannot treat your program like a la
carte or like a buffet you just can't
miss a step you can't do one thing and I
and I've I've got myself to this point
by listening to you and listening to the
other examples but I haven't done it the
correct way and it's no way to do it but
if I downsize by a 300 000 house or
maybe three hundred ten thousand dollar
house uh I'll be totally debt free and
set myself up in a better position uh to
retire and Dave I had a very bad
argument with my wife last night and she
doesn't want to move
that is correct sir yeah don't move
it will not I mean if we have a nice
house but it's big and it's the
maintenance of it doesn't want to move
if she doesn't want to move
that's right
you're 63 years old
there's a chance you're going to spend
30 years with her
yes you don't want her pissed off for 30
years
[Laughter]
all right
yeah okay now what I what I think is
fair
is to say the reason I brought this up
is because I'm scared
I'm afraid we're not gonna have a good
retirement and I was trying to figure
out a way to stabilize this
if we're going to stay here
I'm going to have to have some help from
you
you're going to have to help
we're going to have to work together I
can't carry this by myself
and you
be an anchor while I'm trying to move
this forward I can't do it that's why I
brought up something as bizarre selling
the house because I'm tired and I'm
scared and you have to help me if we're
going to stay in this house
otherwise we're going to have more of
these fights because I'm scared and I'm
tired of doing this by myself and I if
if you want to stay in this house I'll
go along with that but the trade-off is
you gotta help you got to get on board
that's a fair ask of her
I'm sorry yeah no that that is that is
perfectly reasonable I I thought you
would see it for more of a financial
standpoint said yes just downsize they
have no mortgage but it's a personal
aspect of this is kind of outweighing
that and I appreciate it yeah because
it's not just your money it's not just
your house it's not just your decision
and unfortunately in times like this
where you you do know best it doesn't
mean that you can just go and act on it
because it you're the two of you are a
unit and you know you you opened up the
call with you know I've tried to get her
on board before have you ever talked to
her in the way that Dave just laid out
no I haven't done it in that manner I
have a I have a tendency of not not
talking not communicating that well with
with my wife the way that you just
presented that yeah
you know and sometimes uh Sharon and I
when we had been married about 10 years
we spent about a year and a half in
pretty intense marriage counseling
because we were attempting to kill each
other
and it wasn't going good and uh you know
a few times since then we've still used
that marriage counselor has become a
lifelong friend by the way we still will
use her it's a lady sometimes we'll call
her and let her referee on something we
cannot get through and we'll say hey
Margaret you ready referee we're going
to come over for an hour and she says
okay and we come over we drop a fee on
her and she referees for an hour and but
but we both respect her enough that we
think we can guide our way through
something we can't figure it out even
after 40 Years of doing this we can't we
cannot get on the same page it doesn't
happen very often but occasionally we
get something we're both bullheaded
about usually one of us will let back
and and go and let let the other one go
I mean is it really a marriage if you
haven't attempted to kill each other I
mean let's be honest about that Dave
until you reach that point you cannot
officially call it yeah oh it's so true
I had a lady one time she said we've
been married 35 years and we've never
had a fight and I said that's because
you lie okay okay man oh man
healthy conflict is healthy conflict is
healthy don't don't avoid it so yeah
Dave you're no different than any of us
in other words you're the same thing but
uh I think the point is is you're
grasping at straws because you cannot
see a way to do this
and keep the house and there is a way to
do this and keep the house you've got
enough years left you have 90 000 in the
bank if we threw sixty thousand of that
at the 150 we've only got 90 to go and
if we knock out 30 a year for the next
three years you're 66 in the house is
paid for and she's in the house she
wants to die in
so let's try to go out that way but baby
doll that means 30 a year that's 2500 a
month and we've not been doing that
because you're not doing that and we got
to do that together if we're going to
stay in this house that's the cost of
the deal yeah I think that if he lays it
out as you so eloquently did which
clearly you learned in counseling
yeah yeah no I mean you just got to talk
it out and say look I and Dr Dr John
deloney when he's on here a lot tells
people look have you bothered to tell
them how scared you are yes have you
bothered to tell them how angry you are
have you bothered to tell them not just
you need to get on board Dave's stuff
that's ridiculous nobody wants to do
that if you bother to tell them how
excited you are about enthusiastic how
much this makes me smile to the idea of
being debt free and we don't
um
uh uh I mean all spouses have a tendency
to say you know I thought you got mind
reading lessons yes with that marriage
certificate and you didn't understand
yeah tell me this makes you smile you
have to tell me this makes you scared
because otherwise you don't know yeah it
makes you tired good advice Dave that's
good good you know fun stuff Jade wash
all Ramsay personality this hour all
here for you people this is the Ramsay
show
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
folks you know that sinking feeling when
you make an offer on a house you love
and then you hear there's another offer
you need the Churchill Mortgage home
buyer Edge super fast pre-approval and a
secured interest rate plus a five
thousand dollar seller guarantee gives
your offer the best chance of being
accepted the home buyer Edge from
Churchill gives you an advantage over
those other guys go to
churchillmortgage.com today to learn
more
[Music]
thank you
foreign
personality is my co-host today thank
you for joining us America we are so
glad you're here hey guys uh time of
year this time of year can feel really
crazy busy the goals you set with
vacations around they can seem distant
or fuzzy but the thing is the kids are
going to be back in school in the fall
we're going to hold hit a whole another
gear and then you're going to Blink and
it's going to be 20 24. you need a plan
now
to refocus on the goals that you set
this year like getting out of debt
Building Wealth taking care of your
mental health maybe pursuing that career
change that you love join me and the
rest of the Ramsay personalities a smart
conference in Chicago we'll be there
September 15th and 16th and we'll show
you exactly how to reach those goals
you'll learn how to get money smart
relationship smart career smart smart
you'll leave with tons of encouragement
Rachel Cruz Dr John deloney Ken comb and
Jade wash all right here to my right and
George camel all speaking and teaching
you smart conferences Ramsey's biggest
event of the year we want you to be
there in Chicago with us in September
early bird tickets are on sale 79 here's
the thing the early bird pricing is
about to run out you want the good price
do it now
ramseysolutions.com events smart
conference Chicago in September don't
miss it this is the Ramsey show thank
you for joining us hey guys if you like
what you hear please hit the Subscribe
button and the follow button and uh
leave a nice five-star review it's a big
deal it changes everything for us we
appreciate that and uh of course share
the show if you're watching or listening
on a method that gives you to
electronically share clip a link or push
a share button that's good uh or if
you're just a listener a viewer a talk
radio TBN whatever just tell people
where we are and we appreciate that we
know a bunch of you are doing that
because there's a bunch of new folk
hanging out so thank you thank you thank
you thank you Nicole Is With Us in
Atlanta hi Nicole Welcome to the Ramsay
show
hi thanks for taking my call sure what's
up
okay well I am a newly divorced single
mom of five children two of my children
are handicapped
um I have been a stay-at-home mom since
and
uh all of my children are under the age
of eight so
um daycare would definitely be too
expensive for me
um I have three of them are going to be
full-time in school in the fall so I
have really been praying about you know
finding a job that suits the needs of my
family both financially and with my time
and what I've felt led to be looking for
is remote jobs
um when we were in the midst of our
divorce
I looked at your budget outline and was
trying to see like okay how can I make a
budget because right now I am living off
of the Social Security disability for
our my two daughters to make sure the
mortgage gets paid the lights stay on
and you know I have other
um government assistance to help with
food and health insurance
covered you kept that I got the house
and I got
um my vehicle that was paid off my name
was on his vehicle but he got it and but
that doesn't matter to the debt
collectors my name is still on it so I
count that as part of my debt he was
supposed to pay attorney fees but he
hasn't that that's on me I do not count
any child support or alimony because he
hasn't paid any and
um so I just I have to find a job that
I've been divorced
six months and why have you not gone
before the judge and taught said he's
not paying the car payment and the child
support and the alimony
I've gotten
um I've got the ball rolling with them
either collecting the money from him or
collecting him
so you know he's they just the problem
is they can't find him
man okay yeah he just took he just took
off
uh he still calls and I have an idea of
where he's at so I've you know I've done
all the necessary things to try to hold
him accountable
and it's just a slow process because
he's not even in the state how much is
your um house payment
my house payment is
um with taxes and insurance altogether
so it's 1085.
all right
um yeah you you've got it I'm just
trying to I'm sorry what a mess you've
been through kiddo I'm sorry
um yeah I was just trying to grab it
some money there and you've already been
grabbing at it and it's not there so
um
so
what what is what are the prospects on
this you feel like you're going to be
able to pull this plan of yours off
so
um I have a wonderful support system
thankfully with my family and my church
and I've told
um Church uh leaders and everything that
these are the needs that I have and I
think that this is what I need to make
to have and me my question was when I
was looking at your budget breakdown
that I had Googled at the time
um I you know I had no income to put
into it so I was thinking okay what do I
need to ask for as a salary in order to
make my ends meet and so I kind of did
the budget backwards I put my mortgage
in and that's supposed to be 25 percent
of my budget so I did my mortgage you
know and you don't but you don't have a
an income that is a permanent thing
right I mean you've got portions of your
income but you don't have your career
income figured out yet
no but I'm trying to figure out what I
need to make she's trying to reverse
engineer it and I don't think you get to
this I don't think you get to decide a
job based on what you need to make
you've got to decide on the right job
um and yeah you need to you need to you
need to be identifying that I need to
make this much but I mean because you
need to make that you can't walk away
from some other things you've got to
look at what you can figure out here
yeah anything at this point anything
that you find that's work from home that
starts today take that until you can
find what I've been doing side hustles
um doing like uh my brother and my
sister have a side business that they do
and I've been doing their social media
networking for them so that brings in a
little bit I've sold about half of the
things that I can sell so far and I'm
still going through things to try and
sell them and that's got an end to it
yeah that's very short term
um so you said you said you said three
of the kids go to school in the fall all
then you've got the two that are at home
even you working from home I mean just
because you're at home you still gotta
work so who's taking care of the kids
while you're working
that's just gonna have to be where I do
some sort of remote virtual job because
that's all I really can do
um I mean I found a program that's for
like a parent's morning out where you
can send the kids to basically a free
daycare for
um three or four hours twice a week so
that would really be a time that I would
hunker down and get some work done yeah
um and then the other times I would have
to work at night when the kids are in
bed because they all go to bed early
enough that I could stay up for three or
four hours because something something
where you're at home you can set your
own hours maybe look into like virtual
assistanting that sort of thing but I
think you're right I think you're on the
right path I think that you've just got
to start getting those prospects lined
up instantly because the selling stuff
the side hustling it's good that you're
doing something but that like Dave said
that's got an into it and that end is
coming really quickly
um the good news is your kids are also
going to school very quickly so luckily
that's lining up for you but stay on
this judge stay on uh whatever that
pathway is to get that alimony and to
get that child support because right now
that that would be a huge Lifeline for
you while you get all of this set up and
stacked up and thankfully you've got a
good Network and a good Community there
to help you out yeah there's when we're
helping people in financial crisis now
your situation was brought upon you by
different things but one of the things
we always do on the okay what can we do
short term to get the income moving
because if we can get the wolf away from
the door you can relax a little bit and
then the second part is what's my
long-term plan yeah okay but they can be
two different plans I've got a good
long-term plan that's going to come out
of my short-term plan but my short-term
plan is breathing oh four walls baby
breathing I mean just keeping the food
in the house and the lights on and that
kind of stuff this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
thank you
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees ever
things back Ed by their
watch and guarantee and shipping is
always free see whyblinds.com is the
number one online retailer of custom
window coverings go to blinds.com now
and save 40 off selected products visit
blinds.com today for more info
foreign
[Music]
personality is my co-host today thank
you for joining us in the lobby of
Ramsey Solutions on the debt free stage
Billy and Melissa are with us hey guys
how are you hi hi we're okay we're
excited and we want to throw up all at
the same time oh gosh well don't do this
thing I'll let you through a few minutes
here without that yeah we'll just stick
with the excitement part hey how much
that of you two paid off uh we paid off
uh 470 thousand dollars okay how long
did this take it took us a little over
12 years wow and your range of income
during that time yeah the range of
income was 70 up to 180. wow love it so
what do you guys do for a living
so Melissa is a stay-at-home mom and I
am a personal trainer uh gym owner and
now I'm helping other gym owners
coaching them with their with their
business for you wow well done good nice
income good jump over 12 years what kind
of debt was your 470 thousand
uh while it was a house yeah wow
uh credit card debt uh student loans
alone with a parent
um a car so medical we had a guy that I
knew from Jiu Jitsu he said listen uh I
can put a fence around your yard a
beautiful fence and you could pay me
later I said awesome that was part of it
oh wow yeah pay me later was real yeah
yeah yeah
so yeah the Jiu Jitsu fits yeah it shall
ever be known as exactly yeah wow so uh
how much is this paid for house worth
uh I would say about 450. yeah way to go
and how much do you guys have in your
Investments uh everything else is about
300. okay so you're almost a baby step
millionaires way to go guys how old are
you two I'm 38. yeah I am 43. I love it
well done boom boom boom boom boom okay
so 12 years ago things changed oh yeah
what happened oh man we had a huge
wake-up call uh one day uh it was
married to my beautiful wife and uh
getting ready for work to knock on the
door
and there's a a really nice but uh
really scary looking guy on my stoop our
car had been hooked up to his tow truck
and uh that was our wake-up call our our
brand new car was repossessed and uh
that was when we realized we had a
problem we were in a complete denial I
didn't even know that there was a risk
of that I had never heard of it I didn't
realize they could happen and it did did
you realize that you were that far
behind on the payment did not I just
swept everything under the rug we
started getting letters for our house
that they were gonna foreclose on us
goodness so it was bad
yeah so what what do you attribute to
that was it just you guys had your heads
in the sand or was it were you going
through a hard time financially how do
you well we were just spending more than
we made
um actually it was funny after we got on
a plan
and um we realized that we actually had
more money once we were on a plan
um we actually we had less money coming
in as an income once we got on a plan
but we had more money beforehand and we
were in so much debt so yeah yeah it was
crazy wow it's not that unusual yeah
there is um
I've never seen any actual research done
on it but having met with and almost
experienced reposition there's something
you feel this weird combination of being
stolen from like violated
and mixed in with this intense shame
yeah like it's my fault that the thief
is in my driveway there's a weird vibe
there y'all know what I'm talking about
yeah it kind of comes up in your throat
yeah and uh you talked earlier about
throwing up this one's real yeah but
that's that's uh yeah that that is a
serious wake-up call yeah and so when
that happens you're like oh and by the
way there's letters on the house and
maybe they weren't kidding yeah well
it's so public too it's like when you
get those letters in the mail no one
sees those but you but when the guy
shows up on your street with the tow
truck that's like Billy where's your car
oh yeah yeah we had an argument that
night going to go pick it up so that was
stressful oh I bet wow
so this moment happens you realize our
money is a hot mess talk about what
happened next yeah honestly uh God just
really used you guys we were in a small
group with our church and never heard of
you guys and he just casually mentions
it and after that we went home did a
little research and we drank the
Kool-Aid hard come on now yeah they're
so weird yeah we uh we did everything we
went through every single step do you do
Financial Peace University or you just
yeah three and then uh one got
interrupted for some reason we were
doing yeah the third time it got stopped
for some reason why maybe yeah
yeah oh wow yeah so uh so yeah so we did
that then we let it uh several times
with our for our church and yeah it was
uh so he got plugged in stayed plugged
in kept doing the class because we all
know that keeps you motivated yep and we
did Legacy uh as well yeah yeah we did
that on our own yeah did everything yeah
like you said drink all the Kool-Aid yes
absolutely and then also I just just to
mention we also applied the same
principles in the business uh so all of
that debt was from previous stuff and
yeah but the business yeah we never took
a credit card for the business right
yeah yeah very very cool very cool stuff
good for you guys well done well done
all right now that you've done it house
and everything on track to be baby steps
millionaire soon how's that feel
amazing I love what you say about how
the grass feels under your feet on your
own property when it's not owed to
anybody and it's so true it's so true
yeah I agree it's incredible our lives
have totally changed there's just a
different feeling our our marriage was
already I would say it was great but
it's gotten even better our family has
gotten better life is just uh is way
better you know a while ago your
business uh probably making different
decisions there absolutely yep calmer
wiser yeah yeah the whole thing that's
generally what happens and uh feel a lot
more in control a little less desperate
yeah yes yeah that's right you can sell
easier when you don't have to sell them
yeah good for y'all well done you guys
what do you tell people the key to
getting out of debt is
well being on the same page is a big
part of it we were listening to the call
before and and my heart goes out to
couples that are not on the same page
because we were in such a desperate
situation and we knew we had to get help
because we didn't know what else to do
and so uh his leadership was really big
in that but just being same mindset same
goal yeah it's been a huge blessing to
do it together I think that's even more
important for us is what it's done to
our our marriage and our family it's
quite a miracle for us to be standing
here and just to think of the change
that's happening in our lives and in our
four children it's uh it's a huge
blessing the other thing I'll add is we
put a lot into growth I heard somebody
else say that also and I agree with that
we invested heavily in our in ourselves
in our marriage our emotional health
it's good give entree leadership a plug
that was definitely a big part of it so
that was I would say those two things
are what jumps out to us very cool way
to go you guys we're proud of you you
got the kiddos with you what are their
names and ages Alyssa is 12. uh Olivia's
eight Sophia's five and our son Julian
is two all right very good we've also
got the live and give box for you the
baby steps Millionaire's book since
you're almost there The Total Money
Makeover book and a Financial Peace
University membership and you can of
course give that away to someone as well
all right Billy and Melissa Alyssa
Olivia Sophia and Julian
from Clarksville Tennessee 470
000 paid off house and everything did it
in 12 years making 70 to 180 count it
down all right let's hear a debt free
scream all right here we go three two
one
[Applause]
man that's awesome wow Financial Peace
University three times three times
Legacy Journey they did it all Dave man
that's amazing fully committed very cool
stuff this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
personality is my co-host today our
question of the day is brought to you by
neighborly your hub for Home Services if
you need work done on your home but
don't know who to trust you don't have
to stress neighborly is your single
source for just about anything you need
done around the home go to
neighborly.com to find available home
services near you all right today's
question of the day comes from Andrew in
West Virginia he says I've paid off
forty two thousand dollars of debt I
built my six-month emergency fund and
finally started baby step four last
March I'm considering pausing retirement
investing so that I can make ends meet
with how expensive everything has become
with inflation I was very excited to
begin saving for retirement but at this
point I just don't see another way for
me to make ends meet without pausing
investing for the foreseeable future
interesting
um
my mind immediately goes to something's
off in your budget because I'm like
where's the other 50 of your income
because let's just assume you're giving
10 off the top let's pretend that let's
pretend your mortgage is at 25 percent
and then you're investing fifteen
percent there's still 50 and you have no
debt where's the other 50 going that's
my first thought Dave
so either I think he has a house payment
that's true uh-huh or we don't know his
income that's true we don't know his
income could could have an ultra low
income that's true you're trying to do
this on 25 000 a year you can run into
that that's facts um but if you're
making an average household income of 65
70 000 a year
um this is not a problem unless you got
something else off something else is off
I I would recommend him check his budget
yes check your mortgage see what's going
on and honestly check out that lifestyle
creep because a lot of times what
happens is you pay off your debt
everything's going well and you start
increasing your lifestyle but it causes
you to not be able to to do the things
that you still need to do and one of
those things is invest so there's a lot
of unknowns in this equation but check
with the budget because the budget holds
it's like blood work it tells you all
things
that's brutal
um the you know here's the thing let's
think about me okay what of the budget
items that we're talking about could
inflation affect okay okay food food uh
electricity water yes and they have gone
up some in some areas depending on the
area
um the uh gas for your car yes okay
um and that could be pretty substantial
miscellaneous crap at
um Walmart yeah there's always the
target crap yep yeah
um but here's the thing
uh the inflation rate was 9.6 percent
let's call it 10. okay and so let's say
you were making
um a hundred thousand dollars a year to
make it easy and we're dealing with 50
of your budget
um and we're dealing with not all of
that has an inflation figure applied to
it right I'm not even talking about two
or three thousand dollars here a year
yeah that inflation has changed your
budget yeah so
I don't think you are identifying the
correct culprit I agree
um matter of fact I'm positive you've
not identified the great culture I think
inflation is not the culprit no it is a
low income a high house payment or some
lifestyle creep or some combination of
those things so um yeah um I agree but
this is a great moment for me to talk
about budgeting since we're talking
about budgeting if you feel like you're
in a similar situation if you're like
hey the math ain't math in I'm running
out of money at the end of my month you
need a budget and you are lucky because
for just a limited time guys I feel like
the ShamWow guy for a limited time there
is a deal that we're offering it's got
my name as the promo code and you can
get every dollar which is our budgeting
software and you can get it for 15 off
now that's pretty substantial
considering that the normal price is 80
so 15 is a big discount fifteen dollars
fifteen dollars more than 15 that's
right 15 is a big discount and not only
that but you get a free 14-day trial so
you can test it out and that's for a
year yeah that's for a year oh that's
right a whole year the whole dollar a
minute or a month is for a year to have
the every dollar plus that's a good deal
it's a great deal and so this this has
your name on it yes well
Dave if you want one they'll give you
one too but for now this one is
everydollar.com Jade well there you go
don't be salty about it
go sign up today get your money right
trust me you're gonna love it
and we're gonna use its name to do it
all right there we go
yeah every dollar is it is literally the
world's best budget it is it's the
world's best budget I've been using it
since day one day Uno since we came out
with it Rachel is with us in Los Angeles
hi Rachel how are you
hi Dave I'm doing well how are you
better than I deserve what's up
appreciate it but my question is around
my mother's trust and my three sisters
Well my two sisters and nine so three of
us total
um and just making sure that we're
protected so she actually
um my mother got married a few weeks ago
to somebody that we don't know we've
never met before he has two kids
um I just want to that's a little weird
are you all estranged
no no not at all yeah it was a very
very dramatic but yeah
um that would be fair we're very close I
thought we were I thought we were close
is it someone she's known for a long
time as friends and they just got
married or just this guy out of the
Clear Blue Sky yeah so yeah so it's um
she does know him and she's known for
about for a few years
um and he's been kind of chasing her
she's been kind of pushing him off
um and then he's been dating for a few
months and then decided to get married
so oh yeah what's your question
so um I just want to make sure that
um
my sisters and I are protected with our
trash she doesn't have much but I am the
executor of the trust
um and they didn't find a prenup so if
anything happens to her or both of them
I just want to make sure that I'm not
what is in the trust
what's in the trust
I know for sure the two properties are
they're titled to the trust the trust is
the owner of the properties recorded at
the courthouse
okay
then they can't be sold without your
signature
okay you're the executor of the trust
right you're the trustee
yes okay I mean you need to see your
lawyer I'm not one but we use trusts in
our Estate Planning and
um if the a trust is like an LLC or
Corporation in that it is a standalone
legal entity that acts like it's human
and it has a name and the name can own
things
and so the building that we are sitting
in is owned by a trust
and so it's not in Dave Ramsey's name
it's in the name of the trust and so for
the building to be sold the trustee has
to sign the documents that's who manages
the trust
um so if uh so however the if the trust
dictates that the uh trustee
has to follow the direction of your mom
and she says for you to go sell it then
you have to follow the direction of the
trust you might be forced to sell it but
she can't go and sell it if it is titled
to the trust without the trustee
signature in most States now you're in
California lots of weird crap in
California on the law and weird laws and
so I and I am not an attorney please go
see your attorney and at a minimum
verify that the trust is actually
holding the title
of the assets
it's entitled to the trust
um how else would it be able to be in
the trust sometimes people form a trust
and then don't retitle the property and
so the property's not really in the
trust they just kind of thought it was
oh that's it's kind of it's called an
unfunded trust meaning you didn't
actually move the crap into the trust
you built this trust to protect
everything and then you didn't move the
stuff in there and so it's of absolutely
no value there's nothing in it it's an
empty lock box interesting yes and so
you know you know I have a lock box but
there's no money in there you know so
like there's no documents in there so
Rachel go see an attorney uh your
attorney if you have one that's help put
the trust together hopefully there's a
family attorney and say all right I want
to make sure I'm able to do the things
that the trust is asking me to do as the
trustee and I need to verify that the
properties have been listed in the name
of the trust and tell me what happens if
Mom
gets influenced by this husband that
I've never met to go do crazy crap what
happens then and get some legal advice
so you're ahead of the curve on this
this
is the Ramsay show
[Music]
hey what's up guys it's Jay if you love
the show and want a deeper dive on your
money Journey we have a Weekly
Newsletter that gives you trending and
helpful articles and tips on following
the Ramsay way just go to
ramsesolutions.com today to sign up for
our newsletter again that's
ramsesolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]
good
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the pots
Moving and Storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show where we help people build
wealth do work that they love and create
actual amazing relationships Jade
warshaw Ramsay personality is my co-host
today and you are listening to a baby
steps millionaires theme hour a lot
going on in that title we're going to be
taking calls from people who have a net
worth of 1 million dollars or greater
only you are welcome to call if that is
you the phone number is triple eight
eight two five five two two five you are
calling because we want to interview you
and learn a little bit about your wealth
how it got there where it came from and
uh where real millionaires come from
there's a lot of Mythology out there
about where wealth comes from it's all
inherited you have to be a rock star a
country music star a sports figure in
order to be a millionaire uh only Crooks
become millionaires all wealthy people
are crooked that's they stole their
money all these other absurd mythology
items that are running around the
culture that people believe and the
problem when you believe them is is it
makes you think it's not for you
and the purpose of this show is to show
you the truth
where do millionaires really come from
by talking to real millionaires I don't
want to talk to your broke
brother-in-law I know he has an opinion
and he votes wrong we don't even need to
ask him okay I want to talk to real
millionaires people who've really done
it a net a millionaire is by definition
a net worth of one million dollars or
greater your net worth is an accounting
figure it is not a feeling it is not a
moral construct
your net worth is what you own minus
what you owe equals net
worth not a salary
it's not a salary it's not an income
it's definitely not your freaking FICO
score and so it's really just your
assets minus your liabilities the net of
those two things the net worth of those
two things when it is greater than one
million dollars You Are by definition a
millionaire well a million dollars isn't
enough this is not a discussion of that
this is a discussion of do you have a
million dollar net worth well it's not a
real million dollar net worth unless
it's all in cash no you're wrong that is
not the definition if you want to define
something as a cash millionaire that's
fine but real estate counts any asset
that can be sold and turned into money
counts that's called an asset minus any
liability any debt that you have net net
net is a million dollars or greater
you're a millionaire Mark is in Chicago
our first millionaire hey Mark what's
your net worth
hi Dave thanks for having me
having me uh 2.9 Million Dollars very
good give me a little breakdown by
category how much in each of the
different things
my retirement is about 1.6
um other savings outside is about a
million and my house is worth about 0.3
300 300 000 house okay cool uh how old
are you
65. good for you and how much of this
2.9 Million Dollars did you inherit
a hundred thousand okay at what point
did you inherit one hundred thousand how
wealthy were you when you got that
uh the problem with words were a little
over a million dollars at the time so
you already you already had the ball
rolling yeah so we can is it safe to is
it a correct statement then to say you
are not a millionaire because of
inherited money
okay good so uh what was your uh range
of income in your working life your
worst year and your best year working
um
average about 90 000 when I started
after I graduated from undergrad my
starting salary was twelve thousand six
hundred dollars a year wow and then
probably within the last couple years
before I retired maybe about 180. good
for you and what was your career
uh certified public accountant CPA good
good so I assume you have an accounting
degree four-year degree
yes what was your GPA
um 3.5 okay cool good and then and then
I went on after a couple years to get my
masters in taxation ah very good very
good are you a book reader or a TV
watcher
um neither to be honest with you more
reading uh obviously the tax law and the
changes and so on that counts yeah
and uh some of the trade journals okay
all right so what advice would you give
to the 25 year old CPA out there that's
listening can they still become worth
three million dollars when they're 65 if
so what should they do
um you need to have some goals in life
and that's what I started out that I had
some goals and then you figure out a
plan to achieve those goals and you
stick with it and you need discipline
without the discipline it's not going to
happen yeah okay did you have fun in
your life I mean did you go on vacations
and enjoy nice things or did you live in
a cave and collect lint
no no no no no we uh we had sun and one
of the plans that I had when I graduated
uh from undergrad one of my goals was to
own race horses which after saving for a
number of years I've been able to do and
that's still part of the fun in our life
besides traveling how many horses do you
own
right now
um uh 50 of one standard bread wow and
that that horse would be valued at what
yeah right now she's probably worth
about 20 grand TOPS oh okay all right so
that's truly hobby stuff excellent well
[Music]
yes we try to make money at it I know I
know but it's not if you told me this is
a half million dollar horse you own half
of it I'd out of 2.9 Million that's but
I mean this is your share is ten
thousand dollars so yeah this is fun
it's fun is what your point is yes yeah
good for you man I'm proud you're a hero
you went out and did it live the
American dream man it can be done Jade I
mean he started making twelve thousand
dollars a year I love that when he when
he started his working life that's just
amazing yeah I mean I know it was a
different time but golly yeah it was a
different time but it's uh not a
different time now and he made 180. okay
so I mean so how did he become wealthy
what'd he say steady slow and steady
slow and steady discipline personal
discipline I gotta believe he was
deadaverse yeah the largest study of
millionaires ever done in North America
done here at Ramsey airtight research
had outside research firms looking over
our shoulder to make sure we weren't
getting into some kind of confirmation
bias or are violating some methodologies
because we're really good at research
but we want to be triple sure this is
air tight research in other words if you
don't agree with the conclusions you're
what's known as wrong okay
79 percent of America's millionaires did
not receive a dime of inheritance
that's 8 out of 10. another five percent
received a small inheritance like five
thousand dollars another received a
substantial inheritance like Mark of a
hundred thousand dollars after they were
already millionaires five and five and
79 is 89 percent of America's
millionaires are mathematically not
millionaires because of inheritance 9
out of ten times you know what that says
to the rest of you that you can do it
and you should do it
this is the baby steps Millionaire's
theme hour on the rimsy show
[Music]
hey guys being free to make your own
medical decisions is a big deal these
days Christian Healthcare Ministries
gives members the freedom to choose the
doctors and providers they want without
the frustration of worrying about
networks and with no waiting period to
join it's a membership-based non-profit
Ministry where hundreds of thousands of
Christians share funds to pay for and
pray for each other's medical bills for
over 40 years chm has helped families
living across all 50 states so cfchm
could be right for your family check out
more today at
chministries.org budget
[Music]
thank you
Jade Washington Ramsey personality is my
co-host today this is a baby steps
millionaires theme hour Ken is in Los
Angeles hi Ken what's your net worth
hey Uncle Dave it is so awesome to be
talking to you I can't believe this is
happening you too sir
thank you my net worth is thank God it
is 1.5 million dollars yay all right
give me a little breakdown by category
yeah it is 10 release date or all paid
for and the rest 90 is an index funds
low cost index funds okay so you said
you said how much is in real estate
about 150k oh 150 000 in real estate
okay and then so one uh
1.3 in mutual funds
in
yes okay
that would be mutual funds yes okay all
right cool and how old are you
I am 42 and my wife is 43. okay
excellent and how much of this did you
inherit
oh I wish no yeah in fact it's the
opposite because I helped my well me and
my wife to help my mom and dad back home
uh during their bankruptcy so we
inherited nothing absolutely nothing not
a dime where's where's back home Ken
for me Istanbul oh wow my wife is Korea
yeah okay wow okay zero so your
household income or your working income
since you began working your best year
and your worst year
oh worse here I had a disability I
couldn't work for like two three years
uh back here is thankfully today uh both
me and my wife combined income including
bonuses and stock options for 490k
490k what do you do for a living
uh I'm a software engineer and I own a
Consulting business on the side and my
wife is a uh she's the co-founder of CEO
of a tech startup oh wow okay all right
and the um you have a degree in software
engineering I have a degree in computer
science computer science yeah I barely
like I barely finished high school I
barely finished college so I'm not the
smartest guy in this one that's for sure
and then you make 490 000 or something's
going right for you um the what's what
was your GPA
it's like as low as possible like 1.5 if
that didn't oh wow yeah if that didn't
get you out I don't even know how it
works okay so uh where did the 1.3
million come from just pure savings
uh uh saving and investing like I don't
think I ever put more than
thousand bucks in the stock market at a
time it's just small drops and ended up
being a lake today an ocean perhaps wow
what made you believe so strongly that
you could do this because you went after
it man I did yeah you know I was so
broke in college today I grew up wealthy
uh you know my mom and dad uh and then I
came to us for college I was just dead
broke and I did not ever ever want to be
broke again so I saved I invested and I
read a book that changed my life very
early like in my 20s you know this book
of The Millionaire Next Door oh yeah
yeah excellent yeah yeah Tom Stanley's
book from 1992. yeah yeah yes that book
I I owe my wealth to that book today so
just a slow steady thousand bucks a
month here and there invested over time
good for you exactly is that the advice
you would give to a younger version of
you listening
it'll just read more books uh like the
way I see it Dave there are two topics
you have to master in life one thing is
money because you interact with money no
matter what and people that one has to
read about money the other one will be
perhaps dealing with people so those two
books I think people should read about
those topics yeah I agree good for you
man well done proud of you hero good
work that's something pretty incredible
42 year old 1.5
million dollar net worth Catherine is in
Fort Worth Texas hey Catherine what's
your net worth
hey Dave my net worth is one point 1.2
million good for you give me a little
breakdown by category
um so I have um it's broken down into
Cash real estate a Roth 401k how much
cash company
oh uh 293 in cash okay how much in real
estate
652 in real estate
is 75 in our Roth 401k
100 000 in equipment company for one of
our side hustles
um 75 000 in cattle because we live in
Fort Worth and
um 22 000 in stock Wow way to go how old
are you
I'm 29. wow look at you a young
millionaire so we we did this together
yeah way to go guys how much of this did
you inherit
uh zero dollars zero okay cool and your
income uh since you started working best
year and worse year
about ninety five thousand
um and now we're up to about 280 000.
cool what's your careers
I'm an
ad I imagine he works in construction
good four-year degrees I'm I know you
have one
yeah yeah
[Music]
yeah and I think General Studies so I
think he had three miners okay cool what
was your what was your GPA
uh mine was three seven and his was
probably two nine you got your net worth
categories broken down to every detail
uh that tells me you're tracking this
closely what drove you to do that
yeah I think you know a lot of it we we
had in our minds that we wanted to be
millionaires by the time we were 30.
um we started doing your um baby steps
when I was 22 I was just out of college
I made my first big girl purchase of a
um a ring a Lexus and
um we were in debt and we were looking
at our our bank account and saw that you
know we were paying 500 a month and
we're like what are we doing okay so we
started listening to your show
um and the million step you know baby
step millionaire theme hour was on there
and we were like you know this is
something that we can make happen if we
we get out of debt so
um we set it as our goal my husband was
30 years old in two months and by the
time we became millionaires and so um
yeah it's just always been a goal of
ours wow good for you very well done so
you were aiming at it very very
specifically and the method you used was
of course getting out of debt and living
on less than you make
really learned through all this is
um you know in baby step one where you
really just do what you can to make that
thousand dollars
well we we took that and just ran with
it until you know we became millionaires
so
and you know it was it was a thousand
dollars and then it was the two thousand
dollars but what we really learned was
you know how to work and how we really
just learned how to make money
that's amazing man I just all I see
through this whole equation is
intentionality and I think that's such a
huge part of this is knowing hey this is
the goal we're gonna do it it takes to
accomplish a goal so how do you how do
you enjoy this what do you do to enjoy
now that you're not just like on that
grind
well first of all we really enjoy
working so that's part of the the
problem but also got us to where we are
um but just I don't know just sitting in
your your house at the end of the day
and saying like look what what we've
done and uh I don't know just I mean we
don't really we don't really go out to
eat at fancy restaurants we don't you
know really do all that that kind of
stuff but
um you know just just but it's not
because you can't it's because it's not
because you can't do it it's because
you're that's just true to your
personality it sounds like right yeah
yeah we're we're the type of people that
like take coupons to Subway after work
and do that kind of thing but um I don't
know it's just the piece that you have
in your mind and knowing that you can
set goals and Achieve them proud of you
way to go hero look at you 30 years old
before you're 30 you become millionaires
30 years old 1.2 million dollars in net
worth why uh listen to this podcast do
this millionaire female hour seven yeah
eight years ago when they're 22 years
old out of school and said oh wait a
minute 500 Lexus payment is for a
I'm not a that's technical get out
of debt so I can be a millionaire by the
time I'm 30. yeah but Dave Ramsey's
stuff's only for four people we don't
help people get rich we don't know
nobody knows who gets rid of doing this
only her
wow that's impressive
this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
[Applause]
finding a high quality real estate agent
can be tough but it can be even tougher
when you're trying to find one in
another city or another state where you
don't have connections if you're
relocating you already got your hands
full you don't have time to search high
and low for the perfect real estate
agent but this isn't the time to just
roll the dice and let Google find you a
dime a dozen agent
and you don't want to hire someone's
Aunt Linda who just got a real estate
license or worse than that Karen
don't settle for average you need an
agent you can trust to help you make
strong decisions and smart decisions we
call these agents Ramsey trusted and
that's because their agents we trust you
know why we trust them they're the best
in the industry they sell a ton of
houses they're not brand new in the
business they're top of the business
they're going to take care of you
because they know how to do that yeah
you don't have the time or energy to
waste and you don't want to get with
somebody who's just getting I mean this
is you got to get somebody knows what
they're doing okay
ramseysolutions.com agents it'll get you
a Ramsay trusted real estate agent
ramseysolutions.com
agents this is a baby steps millionaires
female or we're talking to real
millionaires people who have a net worth
of greater than one million dollars a
net worth is defined as your assets
minus your liabilities what you own
minus what you owe equals your net worth
if you have a million dollar income and
no money you are not a millionaire
your income does not cause this to
happen I heard an idiot Congressman the
other day say well he's not a
millionaire he doesn't make a million
dollars a year and I'm like this is how
do we elect people like you that are
illiterate but yeah it's disheartening
yes
a U.S congressman wow woman yeah yes
crazy crazy okay so we're talking to
real ones if you're a real millionaire
call me I want to know how you did it I
don't care where it came from you could
have hit the lottery uh you could have
gotten inheritance you could have
started a company uh you could have done
it slow and steady I don't care how you
did it I want to know want to hear from
you what the real story is the phone
number here is triple eight eight two
five five two two five John is with us
in Denver John your net worth is what
uh right at about two two three days
excellent give me a little breakdown by
category how much in each category
uh one four in uh IRAs with uh an
investor investment firm in there in
Aiken South Carolina where my parents
used to live I've got I've got about
um 25k left in my 401k I moved most of
it over since I'm getting ready to
retire soon I moved it over to my
investment counselor and then
um I've got about 600 Grand in equity in
my house and 200 Grand in a paid off
rental property that used to be my
parents so okay cool how old are you
I am 61 looking forward to 62 in two
months good for you good for you and how
much of the 2.3 did you inherit
uh probably about six hundred thousand
dollars today
were you already a millionaire before
that happened or was that before
it was already a million Aire okay so
you did not become a millionaire
mathematically your first Million by
inheritance but you did have a nice bump
after
yes sir and it sounds like you're
referring to your mom and dad so this
was when they passed I'm guessing yes
sir okay cool and you're working
lifetime what was your best income
producing year and your worst
uh
uh just over 500
okay and the worst was I would have been
one of those early years you know uh
probably 548 dollars
I got you okay cool and what was your
career
uh and then I'm an accountant I mean I I
run the business operations for a
contractor that operates our nation's
technical demilitarization facilities ah
okay
but you're a CPA or an accountant by
trade
yes sir and that was your degree yeah
not a CPA just that I'm an accounting
major in college yes sir okay not an MBA
so okay all right and what was your uh
GPA
um to
graduate close to about three nine good
yeah I get serious then yeah okay and uh
okay so
what is your uh you do you hear uh the
voices in the culture that we hear
telling people this can't be done do you
know what I'm talking about I do yes sir
that personally frustrates me because
it's not true and then it tells people
it I call those people hope Stealers
because if they steal someone's hope
then they won't go do what you have done
uh and so you know it's doable uh do you
think it's still doable today
I know it's still doable today Dave my
oldest son owns three homes two of which
are rental properties and my youngest
one owns six five of which were nipple
properties
and so they're in their what 30s or 40s
and they are millionaires too yeah
they're getting there yes sir the oldest
one is about 37 the youngest is about
32. okay and they're well on their way
to being millionaires if they're not
already
yes sir okay very cool so what advice do
you have to the younger version of you
that's listening out there
um the best advice I ever got a
professor in College of mine uh said
what would you have if you put two
thousand dollars a year
into a 401k or an IRA because back then
that's what your max was that's right it
was yep and so I I you know looked at
that and I came up with like 980
thousand dollars I was like wow that's
pretty good so yeah so that's that would
be my recommendation just figure out a
way to to throw money at uh a 401k or an
IRA every year and the other main the
other main thing is to always ties oh I
love that so making giving a major
priority in this whole thing
yep wow what I'm hearing here and I I
mean there's a a
good side of this it can work out in
your favor and or negatively but there's
a mentality here that's clearly been
passed down because clearly his parents
had money and now he's has money and his
kids now are millionaires and John I
think I mean am I right there that this
is a way of thinking this is a way of
working this is a way of handling our
money that we're not only doing
ourselves but we're teaching our
children to do right that's exactly
right my parents never made more than
six figures in their lifetime and both
of them work and uh when they retired
they still saved money out of their
Social Security checks not to mention
what they got in pensions
um so they were saving just about every
penny they had and uh their net worth
increased probably four hundred thousand
dollars in retirement wow and I think
that's right I think that's what's so
incredible about that it's when we talk
about changing your family tree that
that's exactly what it looks like and it
you don't have to make five hundred
thousand dollars a year to do this is
the lesson that I'm taking away from
this anyway yeah that's true yeah very
good well done sir proud of you hero man
look at you you did it you're actually
worth 2.3 million dollars so cool you're
61 years old that's very fun uh one of
the myths that people believe is only
the Uber smart
become Millionaires and actually what we
find is the typical millionaire has
around a 3.1 GPA his was 2.9 in
undergrad 3.9 undergrad we got a 1.5
earlier right right 3.7 and a 3.5 mine
was 2.97 and if you haven't heard I'm
desperately bitter about that three one
hundredths of a point
um I probably attribute it to beer but
um the um but the point is you really
can't be like dumb right but you don't
have to be Uber smart you don't have to
have a 4.2 you don't have to be like a
savant well there's different ways of
being smart everything's not like the
book the book test smart you could be
smart in other ways you could have like
common sense that's right there you go
maybe you know about that well you know
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
all right
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
Jade warshaw Ramsay personality is my
co-host today this is a baby steps
millionaires female or our scripture
today Proverbs 22 29 do you see a man's
skillful in his work he will stand
before Kings he will not stand before
obscure men
kale Sanderson three-time Olympic gold
medalist in Freestyle Wrestling said
unless you continually work evolve and
innovate you'll learn a quick and
painful lesson from someone who has wow
Chicago
hey Kyle welcome to the Ramsey Show
how you doing Dave better than I deserve
what's up
not too much
your net worth is
1.32 cool give me a little breakdown by
category
uh so about 350 in cash
um about 115 120 in brokerage about 60
70 in retirement and then the rest is in
real estate
okay sorry a little bit of business
value uh too I'm self-employed so a
little bit of about 700 in real estate
give or take all right cool a little bit
more than that okay and uh your age I'm
32. okay all right excellent and how
much of this did you inherit
zero okay and what was your best year
working and your worst year working so
far
uh worst year was about negative five
thousand dollars a handful of years ago
and uh absolutely terrible year of
business
um and then the best was about 250.
cool what do you do
uh Landscaping snow plowing uh exterior
lighting you know it's just small
business type of stuff so when you talk
about cutting grass oh I feel that one
yeah I hear you man okay you have a
four-year degree
no no High School
uh yes what was your GPA in high school
um A's and B's I don't remember the
exact number
um but it just they've you know nothing
too crazy nothing you know out of the
ordinary just kind of just got by but it
didn't so you're a 32 year old high
school graduate that has a 1.3 million
dollar net worth from running a
landscape company
yep it started it when I was so
impressed walking pushing mowers down
the street and it just kind of grew it
grew it grew it and then kind of
increased the value by adding different
services and skills and kept at it boys
and girls and whiners Across America
listen carefully here's where money
comes from work
oh my God you work you outworked
everybody
I mean there's definitely been enough
100 hour work weeks in there but it is
uh wow you know just sometimes you got
to just put your head down and work wow
hey can I ask what's your what's your
relationship with debt been like like
what's your thought about that
um I'm
so I'm not a hundred percent with you
guys on the everything that free but I
use them as different kind of levers so
like I have two houses paid off but two
houses have mortgages so I kind of keep
a healthy balance in case of
I get injured or something you know uh
all the trucks are paid off for the
company so for the most part data verse
for the most part
yeah yeah but when I do like take on
something with debt I try to uh you know
pay it off as quick as possible but I
also have a large cash cushion for you
know so the you know a safety measure
yeah so let's pretend that the local
high school there in your neighborhood
invites millionaires to come and speak
and you go and speak in a a kid who's a
senior in high school says uh hey Kyle
America's broken you can't be a
millionaire today
it's easier today than it's ever been
why because because so many people don't
want to work that's opened up so much
more opportunity for the people who do
come on come on come on I love that
I love that awesome all you have to do
is be willing is basically what you're
saying
and like I do I cut grass you know
that's only a small part of what we do
but I cut grass there's nothing special
fancy or Difficult about it you know
it's just you got to get out there and
go every time the grass needs cutting
you never miss and then along along the
way you figure out where you can add
more value increase your skill set now I
could climb trees and remove trees now I
could do low voltage lighting so I
didn't just stay stagnant with cutting
grass I expanded myself my value my
skills to increase my income
I love every bit of this call you are
amazing you're an absolute hero Kyle
thanks a bunch man congratulations hero
so very proud of you when you can make a
million when you can have a million
dollar net worth cutting grass at 32
years old everybody else just needs to
shut up just that's a mic drop there's a
mic drop just shut up
just shut up and what he said is so true
let's just scream and throw a fit and
whine and melt down and say oh you can't
you know I need I need fifteen dollars
an hour and I don't even show up I need
20 an hour and I don't even show up
and uh but because you know it's it's
just America is not fair life's not fair
well I tell our kids what growing up the
fair is where the tilt of whirl and the
cotton candy is
let me tell you about Fair fairs you get
off your fair butt and get to work
that's where fair is and then you will
find Fair it'll show up at your door and
show you know then you'll be able to
afford to go to the fair
if you quit whining about everything
being fair wow unbelievable yeah I'm
sorry uh you're not entitled no and he's
not entitled what a cool guy yeah very
cool I mean 32 years old I mean he's
just made really great decisions he took
what he knows how to do and he's like I
can make a business out of this I can
find a way to make money out of this and
just little by little continuing to grow
I mean obviously it's not like a
straight path you know you have good
years and bad years but he just
continued on with it and here we are I
just think that that's phenomenal so
today on a baby steps Millionaire's
theme hour we talked to five
millionaires 2.9 1.5 1.2 2.3 1.3 million
dollar net worth 65 years old 42 29 61
and 32 years old GPH 3.5 1.5 3.7 2.9 and
3.0 from high school these are our
millionaires for the day the number of
them that inherit their wealth they
became millionaires because of inherited
money was precisely zero
nine out of 10 American millionaires
started with nothing inherited some
money maybe but only after they were
already millionaires ninety percent of
America's millionaires did not become
millionaires because of inherited money
89 detailed research has proven that no
they're not we didn't talk to a single
person who was a professional con artist
or crook oh look at that he did not
steal their money wealthy people are all
not thieves that's the dumbest but Karl
Marx thing you could ever say you must
vilify the wealthy in order to destroy
them with Anarchy that's called
communism seriously this is a it's
the it's the Karl Marx Playbook to
vilify the wealthy when instead in
America some of the nicest best people
you ever meet became wealthy because
they're some of the nicest best people
you'll ever meet and they served and
they helped and they showed up and cut
your grass and they did your accounting
and they were nurse practitioners and
they were software engineers and they
were CPAs today not a single one list
did crook as their career track that's
right we also didn't talk to any NBA
stars yeah we didn't talk to any rock
stars nope I don't know if any of these
people can even play the guitar that's
right and they look they weren't all 80
years old either what do you know about
that you can be young and they had good
lives yes they enjoyed themselves I just
love debunking these myths yeah it's
just I just love it yeah yeah you guys
you gotta believe the truth in order to
act on the truth if you believe the crap
that is floating around in our culture
it causes you to be stagnated yeah don't
believe it that's why we do this baby
that's why we wrote the new book this is
the number one bestseller baby steps
millionaires because they became
millionaires by doing the baby steps
that's right there is great hope out
there America is not perfect but it is
the best chance on the planet you have
for the little man to succeed that is
not a patriotic statement that is that's
the statistical freaking fact oh my gosh
people seriously get it get you some oh
my gosh it's unbelievable Jade washer
good hour proud of you thank you guys in
the booth the booth dudes made it happen
again excellent job guys we'll be back
with you before you know it in the
meantime remember there is ultimately
only one way to financial peace and
that's to walk daily with the Prince of
Peace Christ Jesus
[Music]
foreign
look if you like what you heard in this
episode and want to know more about
getting started on the Ramsay baby steps
go to ramsesolutions.com and click the
get started button we'll help you figure
out the best next step for you based on
your specific situation that's
ramseysolutions.com and click get
started
[Music]